Hello, Mr. Kishibe!
It's such a nice day!
MINORU KAIGAMORI, AGE 23, EDITOR
What are you reading?
De Staël.
Dostarl?
Is it a new band or something?
He was a Russian artist. He died in 1955.
Listen, Kaigamori.
ROHAN KISHIBE, AGE 27, MANGA ARTIST
Of course,
it's absolutely unacceptable
for a professional to be late
for a business appointment, but…
it's also not right for an editor
to arrivesix minutes early
for anappointmentwith a manga artist!
I'm sorry. So coming early is wrong too.
You were lucky it was me this time.
Now, let's talk about my next 61-page
one-shot manga, shall we?
Excuse me, Mr. Kishibe!We are yourfans!
Could we have your autograph?
Please write "To Akira"!
No, no! No autographs, you two!
Mr. Kishibe is busy! He's working!
I've signed them already.
Unlike some, I'm a fast worker.
I always give my autograph
to thank my fans.
Wow! How did you do that?!
Drip painting using coffee!
Thanks, buddy. You rock!
Gotcha, gotcha, gotcha!